robinson a deep three
and that's why he's amongst league
leaders in three-point shooting shot
45 getting a lot of attention but jimmy
butler
creates a little bit and go down you
feel like oh this is my day
so this is the first one off the jimmy
butler just sort of
draggage for three jay crowder
underneath with a nice board
robinson again and he's two for two from
d
minutes to go here in the first half of
game two
on the drag screen hero great ball
movement that's the guy
that you want shooting at duncan
robinson who shoots 45
from downtown excellent offense turning
the corner tyler
creates a two on one brockton gets
caught in the middle and jay crowder
finding duncan and that is just the
shorts they're in it and it's
competitive
duncan robinson inside got it back
little pitch and catch
that's a very popular action that the
heat use butler on the assist
a lot of contact underneath robinson
left open
and that is lethal offense
miles turner couldn't get out that's a
that's a too long of a closeout
for miles adebayo might have a chance to
do that if you're looking the other way
off
the rim and then the pitch ahead somehow
the pacers leave the hottest shooter on
the floor
[Music]
shot clock down to six robinson rising
up
man he is still hot that is rare though
one for seven as robert orry did
but again most the vast majority
assisted but he recognizes shoot we got
to get one off here
great job getting back square i said
shoot we got to get one off here
great job getting back square